people often ask me what's the most
memorable thing that's happened to you
because you or Nobel laureate Harold and
I were asked to throw out the first
pitch at a World Series game
now the baseball fans who are watching
know what a big deal that is and the
Giants were playing the Oakland
Athletics in the World Series that year
so we were lined up to throw out the
first pitch at the fourth game which was
fine I mean they had it's a minimum of
four games in the World Series but at
the third game there was an earthquake
tragic earthquake this was in 1989
killed 20 some people in the East Bay on
a freeway and we were in the ballpark
for the third game of the World Series
and that earthquake occurred that was
something else
and then I got a phone call but first
there was some discussion about not
finishing the World Series to ake the
ACE had humiliated the Giants in the
first two games of the series that was
important and what happened followed so
they talked about not finishing his
series of respect for the people who
were killed and eventually decided no
will finish it so I got a phone call
from the Commissioner of baseball
telling me that they were going to
change the order in which we threw out
the first pitch that for the third game
which didn't get played because of the
earthquake they were going to have
heroes of the earthquake 20 threw out
the first pitch rest you know first
responders etc and then Willie Mays
would be moved from third to fourth game
and we were moved to the fifth game and
I said commissioner I don't like that
I've saw the
first two games they're not going to be
a fifth game and the Commissioner pushed
back and said doc come on you we don't
even talk about four game world series
down here in my office and after some
quick thinking I said look you had 20
people or you're gonna have 20 people
throw out the first pitch for the third
game why can't harness and I'd join
Willie Mays and throw out the pitch for
the fourth game so we were sure to get
to do it there was this long pause then
he said let me get this straight
doc you Varmus and willie mays is that
right yes sir doc get real it didn't
happen the AIDS swept the Giants in four
games and we threw out a pitch at the
Dodgers game next year
Giants won I have the ball still
you